hello good morning welcome to sky news
breakfast thank you for joining us this
morning the foreign office says china
must provide verifiable evidence that
missing tennis player feng shui is safe
the former wimbledon's doubles champion
has appeared in another video released
on twitter this morning with chinese
state media saying that she attended the
opening ceremony of a youth tournament
in beijing
the editor-in-chief of the global times
the official newspaper of china's ruling
communist party claims that miss pung
has been staying in her own home freely
and will make a public appearance soon
she disappeared after accusing china's
former vice premier of sexual assault
well let's get more on this story now
from sky's tom cheshire
who's at the national tennis centre in
beijing so tom is this new video
providing any reassurance at all
i think it does provide some reassurance
actually to that question the hashtag
which so many have been asking very
loudly where is pangshwai the videos
released
show her apparently in beijing the first
one uh released last night she has heard
a restaurant in the city center
apparently with friends um according to
uh the editor of the global times the
newspaper you mentioned uh they
mentioned the dates quite a lot five
times in the same video which is uh an
odd thing to do probably with friends
but supports the belief this may be a
sort of proof of life video the other
video was released today it shows uh
punch y at a tournament a youth
tournament in the stadium behind me um
we've been trying to follow up on that
we went to that restaurant earlier today
we asked the staff whether panchoi had
been there and they said yes she had
been there they hadn't seen them her
themselves because they've been very
busy but she had been there and we went
into the stadium uh earlier and before
we asked it out we spoke to
one staff member there who said he had
seen her as well so that question of
where she is i think that is being
answered belatedly by chinese state
media but this isn't of course just
about the question of where is she it's
about what are her circumstances what
sort of control is she perhaps under
after making those you know really
sensational allegations about a very
high-ranking chinese official uh jan
gali who used to be the vice premier
that he sexually assaulted her uh she
made those in november the second that
post was taken off very very quickly and
we hadn't heard from her until then we
have these proof of life sort of videos
if you want to think in that way now but
i don't think that is sufficient it's
certainly not sufficient uh for steve
simon who's the chief executive of the
women's tennis association after seeing
those videos he said this while it is
positive to see her it remains unclear
if she is free unable to make decisions
and take actions on her own without
coercion or external interference this
video alone is insufficient as i've
stated from the beginning i remain
concerned about punctualized health and
safety and that the allegation of sexual
assault is being censored and swept
under the rug i've been clear about what
needs to happen and our relationship
with china is at a crossroads when he's
talking about that crossroads
there is this threat from the wtnr that
they won't play matches in china they
say they can't do that while one of
their players has been missing for so
long it's simply uh not something they
can do put that sort of revenue ahead of
the rights of the players and as it
makes clear that video is not enough to
answer those questions especially about
those allegations about sexual abuse
when uh pancho i made that post on weibo
the wta straightaway said there needed
to be an investigation they are still
pushing for that we do have a little bit
more news today with with these videos
and that is welcome news but certainly
not enough to answer all the sorts of
questions that surround this case
tom in beijing thank you
now more protests have taken place in
major cities in europe against new
measures to contain covert 19 is as
cases surge across the continent
in austria tens of thousands of
protesters have marched through vienna
and other cities protesting against the
nationwide lockdown which starts on
monday the crowds also demonstrated
against the vaccine mandate which will
make it legally compulsory for citizens
to receive the covert jab
in the netherlands police arrested seven
rioters in the hague on saturday night
is after demonstrators started fires in
the streets and threw fireworks at
officers
protests also took place in amsterdam
and the southern city of breda
local media reports that some officers
were injured the unbreasts came after a
day after police fired warning shots at
protesters in rotterdam
tens of thousands of croatians also took
to the streets yesterday to protest
against the country's vaccine mandate as
well as tougher covered restrictions
with a population of about 4 million
people croatia has one of the lowest
vaccination rates in the eu
and in north macedonia demonstrators
also gathered in front of the parliament
and marched through the capital skopje
they're protesting against calls from
authorities for health workers and other
government employees to face compulsory
vaccinations against covert 19.
now bringing it back here to the uk and
bookings for coronavirus booster jabs
will open for people aged 40 and over
this week now from monday 16 and 17 year
olds will also be able to book their
second dose of the vaccine the
department of health is continuing their
push to get people jabbed up hoping it
will help to keep cases down over the
christmas period well that comes as
health secretary has launched a review
into possible racial bias in medical
equipment after fears that thousands of
patients from ethnically diverse
communities died from covid when they
should have survived
let's get more on this now from our
political correspondence rappal who's in
westminster for us now so um rob uh when
are we expected to get the findings of
this review and also what is it likely
to throw up
there's some suggestion um in the papers
that the initial findings of this might
come early uh next year in january but
we haven't had any specific timeline yet
not really any details either about who
actually will be carrying out this
review but what the health secretary
sajit javid who's announced this in a
piece in the sunday times this morning
has said in terms of what he wants to
see is he essentially wants to make sure
that all different medical devices work
properly for people of all different
races
and genders
as well
and what's led him to announce this is
specifically a potential concern
around a medical device called a pulse
oxymeter now
basically pulse oxymeters are pretty
common devices you clip them on the end
of your finger they shine beams of light
uh that then are able to pick up they go
you can see them now on your screen uh i
can give an indication of how much
oxygen a patient has um in their blood
now there's been concerns actually for
quite a while now that they may not work
as well for people um with darker skin
and that and there is some research that
shows that that can lead to inaccuracies
in the readings around oxygen levels
in blood now clearly the amount of
oxygen you've got in your blood is a
crucial measurement when you're being
treated for covid so i think the worry
is is that if people with darker skin
are getting inaccurate readings via
pulse oxymeters that maybe they're not
getting the appropriate treatment or the
necessary treatment
and that may well
have contributed to the
disproportionately high rates
of death among people from ethnic
minority backgrounds from covid so what
sergeant javid wants to see is
international standards that guarantee
that medical devices are tested on
people from all racial backgrounds
before they
are put out to the market as well
obviously that's part of the reason why
these discrepancies might
might be thrown up a lack of sufficient
testing but sadja javid also in this
piece talks about
the need essentially for more diversity
amongst people who are designing and
making that equipment and clearly that
is an issue that is a far broader one
and can't really be fixed just with a
review
robin westminster thank you
now the future of westminster of
manchester united manager oligonosula
remains uncertain club officials
discussed his police position following
a 4-1 loss at watford that's the fifth
defeat in seven premier league games
oscar studio chaldry is at old trafford
for us now sadia good morning to you for
one loss at watford another humiliating
defeat is the writing on the wall then
for oligarchia
good morning well yes i think the
writing's been on the wall for some time
now but we've always known that if
manchester united were going to sack him
they're not going to do it they're going
to try and do it in the right way for
example we were told that they wouldn't
sack him at an away ground regardless of
what the performance or result was but
it is going to be a sad day for some
united fans when that comes because
remember um oligarchy has such a
standing at this club not just a manager
but previously also a player so he's
seen them through some tough times and
many of them still supporting him right
uh the way through those difficult uh
weeks that they've had and you know you
just had to see his post-match comments
last night you feel sorry for him he he
smiles through a lot of these very
difficult answers um that he has to give
but we were at the airport last night we
saw the players and some of the coaching
staff return and their faces
showed their disappointment after that
result last night but the writing as i
say has been on the wall for some time
there was a talk of manager being
replaced after the liverpool defeat that
was a five-nil defeat here at home to
one of their biggest rivals in the talk
then started about how he should be
replaced but then they went on to beat
tottenham away and again that was then
seen as a catalyst perhaps now the you
know his strategy is beginning to work
they played more compact slight more
intensity but actually if you watch that
game it wasn't united that were good it
was tottenham who were really bad and
perhaps they were the overall winners
because they swiftly changed things
around change their manager and got they
appointed a manager
who united fans wanted at their club
antonio conte and timing was very
crucial as well because they did that at
the start before the international break
which gives new managers to clubs a real
chance to get to know their club without
the pressure of games united if they do
make that announcement today then it
comes ahead of a champions league game
against vrl on tuesday and next
weekend's game against tabletoppers
chelsea on sunday
sadia thank you
well it's now exactly a year to go until
the 2022 world cup kicks off in qatar
but fifa's decision to award the country
the right to host the cup back in 2010
has proved controversial to say the
least with campaigners criticizing the
qatari's human rights record well let's
get more on this now from our reporter
k2 banfield so katie is fifa concerned
at all that qatar's human rights record
could cast a shadow over the games
absolutely it is vanessa you know this
is due to be the first world cup ever
held in the middle east supposed to be
this huge milestone for fifa but
criticism has been mounting for years
now not just over the way that uh the
country was actually awarded this
tournament in the first place but also
over things uh like its record on
working conditions and as you say uh
human rights let me just take you
through uh some of that controversy in a
little bit more detail so there is huge
concern for instance over the way
migrant workers have been treated in
preparation for the tournament with a
report by amnesty for instance accusing
the qatari government of forcing them to
work in dangerous conditions and
withholding their salaries this is a
country of course where it's still
illegal to be gay so there are also big
fears about how the human rights of
lgbtq plus individuals will be protected
and many sports stars both within
football and outside have been pretty
vocal about this issue including
f1 driver lewis hamilton who will be
wearing a ramo helmet at the grand prix
in doha later today and of course the
world cup is typically held in the
summer but there have also been
controversies
over the timing of it next year it's
been pushed back to november
so the players and fans can cope with
the climate but this means it's actually
due to be the shortest
world cup since 1978 at just 28 days and
as i mentioned the way that qatar was
awarded this tournament has also come
under fire with organisers denying
allegations from the u.s that bribes
were paid to secure votes back in 2010.
now the ceo of the qatar world cup has
chosen today this moment one year to go
to hit back at some of that criticism
saying qatar has been unfairly treated
and scrutinized for a number of years
the amount of achievements that have
been done over the past seven eight nine
years it's quite extraordinary i think
qatar is a trailblazer right now with
all the reform that it's done of course
the issue of human rights in
international sport has come under even
sharper focus at the moment with the
disappearance of the chinese tennis
player pong shui that we've also been
discussing this morning so as much as
qatar might want some of this criticism
to disappear now highly unlikely it's
going to anytime soon
katie thank
you well i'm now joined by sportswriter
at the daily mail and mail on sunday ian
herbert so
thank you very much indeed ian there you
are so like in just a year to go and
many people will be wondering there and
how did qatar which is not known for its
football it's not really a football
nation is it how did it end up hosting
the world cup
well i mean it sold itself um very
strongly um
it uh it smooths the fifa executives um
i think your your package there hinted
at the the allegations that it sort of
really bought the world cup qatar has
always
resisted that most strongly but of
course when you come to the reality of
it she just said it was it was actually
the idea of holding it in the summer as
usual even that became totally
impractical because it would have been
you know feverishly hot in it and it had
to be moved to the winter for the first
time ever so
uh i mean muddy talk as it always does
in sport that's why they got the world
cup but uh you're now in a situation
where it's being bundled into
the qatari winter into the middle of the
premier league football season
um and actually also into a very very
tiny gulf state that you know you do
wonder whether the fans of 32 nations
are really going to be able to to cram
into that place it's not just a nation
it's a city within a within a small
nation
um it's interesting you said money talks
there but actually i wonder if that
money is enough then to silence people
when it comes to the country's human
rights record and criticizing them
because that's bounty class to shadow
isn't it over the game or will it what
do you think well it yes it will it will
i think when the football starts as
always with these things uh you know
the sport will come to the fore but i
think there'll be an awful lot of
well there will be noise around the
human rights when the tournament starts
we already know that the danish team who
qualified for example they'll be wearing
when they train out in doha when they're
at the tournament they'll be wearing
train shirts with human rights messages
on
um you know we wait to see whether
others will will speak out we wait to
see whether england will speak out
um
but
between now and then i think there will
be a lot of noise i don't think they
will get the
glossy pr that they're hoping for i mean
you mentioned that interview with the
the leader of what they call the supreme
committee
uh uh
earlier today um the fifa uh chief
president uh gianni infantino has also
issued his own statement really
suggesting that qatar has made huge
strides in in relation to human rights
but i was over there a couple of weeks
ago for for over a week and
that's not really what i saw you know i
saw workers who
looked pretty desperate and were working
under unbearable conditions really with
no protection
and on just a pittance
now um
ian before i let you go let's talk about
oligonosia um
4-1 defeats to watford humiliating um to
say the least really and this is not the
first humiliating defeat that they've
had
what's going on what went wrong
well i mean i i you know i
i was arguing that his permanent
appointment as manager was questionable
in the first place
you've got to reel back a couple of
seasons though he came in at the back
end of the season they did all right um
and on the basis of not very much he was
given you know a permanent contract
uh they've really been tanking you know
for for weeks they're a very
undercoached side they don't seem to be
across the tactical demands of the of
the premier league
uh terrible defeat yesterday as you say
but the difficulty now is that halfway
through the season you know a club like
united need
you know a certain type of manager we
need to grab the whole club by the
scruff of the neck and there are a lot
of lot of people available i mean
zinedine zidane is
uh you know they're available um the
obvious candidate but it's difficult to
see how he's the kind of character who's
going to rebuild man united i mean he
doesn't speak very good english
uh he's not really got a reputation for
for
for building a club from the bottom up
and i mean they're in a real fix
ian herbert sports writer at the daily
mail and mail on sunday thank you
so the big question then the weather
what can we look forward to let's take a
look
well it has been very mild so far this
month but northerly winds will take will
make it much colder for the next few
days it's cold now with temperatures
generally in low single figures celsius
but a raw wind means that most places
are just about frost-free
inland areas will be mainly dry with
good sunny spells through the morning
but there will be some blustery showers
for exposed northern western and eastern
coastal areas wintry on the northern
hills
and it will be chilly with a bitter wind
particularly near the coasts
most places will stay fine through the
afternoon although showers will spread
across more of eastern england for a
time and they'll tend to die out later
becoming largely confined to north sea
areas by the evening
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
now giving birth in the uk is becoming
critically unsafe that's according to
organizers of visuals being held by
midwives across the uk today
staff shortages and a lack of funding
are being blamed for putting women and
their babies at risk and i'm now joined
by experienced midwife and member of the
march with midwives steering group elsie
gill elsie thank you for your time on
sky news this morning now you are
practicing midwives as i said taking
part in the march how do you feel about
your industry at the moment what's
morale like
well good morning vanessa um and thank
you for having me on to talk about this
it's a very important juncture in terms
of our service in maternity
in the uk at the moment because
for many many years now it has been
underfunded it has been struggling
and
the pandemic has actually
lifted the carpet to see
exactly what's going on because with the
restrictions the necessary restrictions
around the pandemic
midwives are struggling to meet the
workload people are leaving
services have had to be reduced or
curtailed in order to fulfill safety
regulations for the pandemic and this
has actually caused a severe crisis in
terms of maternity services now a
profession that we love and we actually
dedicate our lives to you know being a
midwife is a fantastic
way to serve society but it is
impossible just now to do it to the best
of our ability because of the
circumstances and the long-standing
issues that we've had in maternity
would you see yourself staying in the
industry or is the pressure becoming too
much for you
i will remain in the service i have been
a midwife for a very long time i now
work in private practice and i'm able
along with another midwife who used to
be my manager in the nhs we work really
closely together in a very timely way we
have autonomy which many of the midwives
in the service do not have at the moment
we have the autonomy to choose our
workload and to choose how it is that we
work and we journey with the women to
birth in the way that they would like to
so we're very fortunate so i don't
anticipate leaving until the time comes
for me to retire from the service
and one of the things you touched on
also is about the pandemic and the the
industry was already struggling wasn't
it with low numbers and then of course a
pandemic hits so that must have been a
bit of a double whammy for you there
yes i think this is what has happened
really the pandemic has actually
escalated the situation in a service
that has been
underfunded
it has been impacted by many different
things that have come to
initially support my bravery practice
but in fact has actually caused a lot of
problems so for example
the
um the insurance scheme which is
supposed to support good practice has
actually had the opposite effect and has
had two or three iterations in order to
improve that so it is a complex
situation and we have to sort of take it
bit by bit and that's one of the reasons
that one of the
asks that we are making of the
government is to listen
to the people who are impacted the
midwives the women the doulas the
families and to understand to get some
real insight into what is happening in
the service that is causing this issue
for all of the people who are concerned
with maternity services
absolutely and from the government what
what will the help look like to you i
mean for example have you heard from the
all-party parliamentary group from
eternity what have they been saying
well the old party parliamentary group i
believe have got a good handle they were
set up some time ago
but what has happened since then is that
the issues for black
and asian and other minority ethnic
women that has come to the fore because
for many many years now there has been
no improvement in the fact that they are
more likely to be negatively impacted by
maternity services so every year we have
a report on the
deaths and damage to women and
black
asian and other minority ethnic women
are
worse impacted by those so
a new all-party parliamentary group has
now been set up to look at those issues
but all the groups that are
attached to maternity services need to
have
good insight into the whole of the
service so that we can actually make a
plan to go forward
elsie gail experienced midwife it's been
a pleasure speaking to you thanks for
your time thank you
for with us this morning's review this
sunday morning's papers are broadcaster
and diamond and chief political
commentator at the independent john
rental and here they are on our screens
and and i noticed that you have started
christmas very early you're kicking
things off
i don't know i'm gonna get it in the
neck no this one already started
i say bring it on okay let's get into
the festive spirit now
and then i'll stay with you because um
this has raised a few eyebrows stories
so it talks about five-year-olds getting
the covert jab
well the times here reports that um
leaked national health service documents
suggest that there are plans within the
nhs now to offer the vaccine uh the
covert vaccine to children aged 5 to 11
in the first half of next year but the
royal college of pediatrics and child
health have said hang on this is
premature because uh and i say why have
a royal college of pediatricians if
you're not going to listen to them they
say that um at the moment um it's there
is a very very very small risk that um
the the fisa jab
in five to eleven year olds may be risky
may cause some sort of a heart problem i
stress a tiny risk but nevertheless the
pediatricians are saying we simply don't
have enough evidence to allay
everybody's fears so it would be
premature to go ahead with a mass
rollout of the vaccine for these little
ones until we can be absolutely 100 sure
and john what do you make of this
possible you know talks about
five-year-olds getting the clover jab
no i i agree with anne um i think there
is no
you know there's no real case for
uh giving medical treatment to uh
children to protect them against
something which isn't a serious risk to
them um i mean obviously there's a
social argument for trying to protect
the entire population
uh but i think uh as anne said
uh if the evidence is not strong enough
then i think you uh you you don't give
it to uh to to have the twelves i think
uh i think we
i think the vaccines are beating the the
virus as it is anyway so luckily i don't
think this issue
arises but i think we should be very
careful about going to younger children
and john um the front page of the
observer has a headline that will
possibly have um boris johnson quaking
in his boots this morning so he says you
know dumb plan again yeah dump plan
fought care charges or face tory
rebellion just give us more context to
this
well this is about the plan for social
care uh which is one of the reasons why
the uh the tory government is going to
raise taxes uh next year um and some
details were published last week which
have been reported as um as hitting um
poor people uh worse than uh than the
better off uh it's very complicated this
and actually what the what the observer
is reporting is a meeting that tory mps
had with the minister jillian keegan uh
where she was unable to answer uh their
questions about the effect of of of this
new plan um
and it is complicated i'm not sure i've
got it right but i i think what's
happening is that this plan is not as
generous
uh for uh for relatively uh poor people
uh than the the plan which uh which was
legislated for in 2014 didn't come into
effect but actually what the government
is proposing is more generous than the
than the current situation i know it
sounds incredibly complicated but i
suspect when it comes to it tory and
people look at the look at the numbers
and they'll and they'll draw back from
voting against the government i think
that really signifies doesn't it you
know social care as a whole and just how
obviously complicated it is for the
government to to tackle so um let's move
on and let's talk about the story that
has really dominated the last few days
this is pong shui who's the tennis
player who made those allegations about
sexual assault um to a former vice
premier of um china and then suddenly we
hadn't heard from her for ages and then
hey ho a video pops up as if we should
all be very convinced and what do you
make about these videos popping up
reassuring us that actually punch why is
doing great she couldn't be better
well i don't feel reassured at all i'm
still worried for her
they may have put out or somebody's put
out a tweet on her behalf and a video
saying she's absolutely fine she's just
staying indoors at the moment but she
will be back normal service will be
resumed but i'm not convinced because we
haven't seen her for a good two weeks
and friends and family are worried for
her
meanwhile of course the winter olympics
is happening in beijing
in february and it is being suggested
that we at least in what they call the
five eyes countries that sort of um uh
intelligence alliance between us
usa australia canada new zealand um that
we consider boycotting the games or at
least not sending our politicians and
envoys to the games
and so there is a call for us to
actually take some sort of stance
against the chinese government here even
if they are going to host the winter
olympics which will no doubt be
spectacular in february this girl is
still missing and i for one and i'm sure
countless others join me in still being
worried for her um john are you
reassured the video says she's fine
well yeah but
th that video is insufficient evidence
that she is fine according to the uh
women's tennis
association
um and you know yes there was another
there was another
video that appeared overnight actually
showing her as a guest at a at a tennis
tournament which i think does actually
is establish that uh you know that's
that's that's the one there um which i
think does establish that she is still
alive anyway
and uh you know there's definitely a
date on that one
um but no it's not reassuring as ann
said it's uh you know this is a
totalitarian regime
and the way they uh
you know the way they respond to
international
outcry is is significant they've you
know i think it does protect her to a
certain extent that the world is
watching and i think the uh the chinese
government will be very careful but uh
you know the question is
you know whether the world will continue
to watch and take action uh by
boycotting or at least a diplomatic
boycott of the olympic games absolutely
and it's also been fascinating to see
the big tennis stars getting involved
and making their voices heard so that's
absolutely brilliant and ann the front
page of the mail there the um royals at
war with bbc over title tattle that's a
word i i just enjoy saying it a
documentary
i mean i this is the daily mail this is
what they love and they obviously know
what their readers want there's nothing
more they like than having to go at the
bbc and and spreading their own sort of
form of tittle tattle or gossip or
whatever about the royals so here we've
got the perfect mix of the royals at war
with the bbc and that the daily mail is
just salivating over it this is over a
documentary that's apparently going to
be shown tonight i think um by amal
rajan the reporter and
he's he's i think there's they're going
to alleging it that there's been a war
of the waleses now we've already known
about this the two princes harry and
william um but what he's saying is that
they've been briefing against each other
and um allegedly apparently has a
documentary proof of this whether and
the palace is saying show us your proof
we demand right to reply uh which i
think is a little high-handed of them
because what other sort of journalistic
outfit would say all right you all have
rounded reply before it's even shown um
but anyway i mean it's a big big row and
it's absolutely a daily mail cup of tea
isn't it on a sunday morning well is it
tittle tattle we'll be keeping an eye on
that then won't we
anne diamond john rental it's been
lovely having you this morning thank you
so much for your time